when that I'm sorry the problem is that
most people expect returns to come
within a year or two that's how long of
a lease they give people um we did a
survey on Twitter where they said how
long would you tolerate a manager
underperforming before you sold that
allocation and it was like 80 or 90%
said under six years and most said under
three there's been survey after survey
that shows institutions are just as bad
by the way where they say they'll give
ninety five percent of managers under
three years and then they fire them but
the academic literature shows that's the
exact opposite of what you should be
doing the three year time horizon most
institutions they've shown this over
10,000 hiring and firing decisions would
be better off staying with the manager
they fired and not adding the one that
they're adding to or including now
because they just revert and if you
don't mind give me a little latitude
here let me give you a good real-world
example I used to tell clients it asked
me say ma'am how long should I give this
strategy and you can extend this to
asset class anything you want
how long should I give it and I used to
say ten years and now I say 20 a good
example is the stocks versus bonds
currently everyone knows stocks
outperform bonds it's been 40 years and
they have it we expect that going
forward no with bonds at almost 0%
interest rates versus stocks you would
absolutely expect stock out before but
that wasn't the case for two years so
you gotta wait well let's use Warren
Buffett everyone knows Buffett's an
amazing investor everyone didn't know
that in 99 Artic walk on articles saying
he's lost his touch he's old fuddy-duddy
and we wrote a book called invest with a
house that you you actually used to
talked to mark a lot about this where
you could track hedge funds what they're
doing through the 13f filing so you
could buy what Buffett buys when it's
public top ten Holdings equal weighted
back to 2000 when the filings became
electronic and that outperforms the
market by about three percentage points
per year that beats 95% of all mutual
funds we didn't have to do anything you
could also buy Berkshire the 13s
outperform by a little bit
it's very close you know do anything it
takes five minutes a year you just hired
the best performing performing managers
on the planet and charlie munger - and
now the new guys but why would never why
would anyone never do that
it's because they go through
ridiculously long periods amount of her
performance buffett is underperformed
we're ignoring what's happening this
year I have no no idea the last 17 years
so of the 20 years he's unformed and
it's like 11 out of 17 calendar years so
every institution every retail investor
would have given him a three-year leash
and then you're fired Warren you're
fired charlie but I just gave you a
prescription to be 95% of all mutual
funds zero cost takes no effort but no
one would have been able to withstand
buffett because of that mismatch we're
talking earlier but this applies to
active management - so going in with all
these asset valuations and the struggle
with with why this is so hard if you
look at the world right now after it's
been imploding the last few months the
good news stock valuations in the u.s.
come down from 30 - I don't know what
today is happening but down to about 20
- so we're back to normal valuations for
low inflation that's great news
it's not back to normal fault period
which would be another 20% from here and
it's not back to the global financial
crisis lows which would be I hate to say
it another 40 percent from here ish and
it's certainly not backed all the way to
five where it's been in before but you
also have to hold in your head the
chance that it could go back to 45 right
or all-time highs if we cure this we
find out that chloroquine works or
there's new vaccine boom we can we can
go back to highs you have to hold both
possibilities in your head and most
investors can't form developed is
probably down to I don't know 15 foreign
emerging is probably straight up at 10
and the cheapest countries we update
this every month every quarter on the
idea forum and send it to investors and
happy to send it to Chios lists a lot of
countries around the world are gonna be
p/e ratios about 5 and about 7 which are
generational buying opportunities these
things you doesn't have to be this week
this month this quarter could be this
year could be next year the things you
could be allocating to where you will
get probably 15-20 percent returns one
word but it's gonna be really hard it's
good you may buy them and they may go
down 20 percent more I got to pause
there I've been blabbering for like 20
minutes so you're still awake listen
it's just a lot it's incredible because
what you're basically elaborating on and
kind of hitting from multiple
perspectives is this idea that if you
are a short-term investor and you want
immediate results one you're likely not
to get them into you're actually gonna
make really bad decisions right because
the if you're looking for that kind of
quick feedback loop of hey I bought
actually didn't return what I wanted in
12 months I'm gonna go change my
strategy it's kind of this belief that
the average is the average for a reason
right and so if you go through three
four or five years of underperformance
well if the average performance is
higher than that at some point it
reverts back to that right it's kind of
the the thing that mark always says
around you know people kind of buy what
they should have bought because it's at
the all-time highs and they think that
it's you know all rosy but then also
they sell what they're about to need so
they sell it after you know a couple
years of underperformance
and then all of a sudden it goes on you
know the run that they were all
expecting three four five years before
and so it really comes down to I think
one the emotional discipline but also to
the ability to understand the math
behind a lot of the decisions right
which was she did a great job of
articulating and just kind of trust that
the math works and what I find when I
talk to a lot of investors is it's
almost like they know the right answers
but they feel like they have to do
something to feel in control right
because if I underperformed two three
years in a row rather than stick with it
if I do something then like now I'm in
charge and I could kind of get myself
out of this and that usually is just a
really bad strategy it's a we had a
quote that we put out in this piece this
past week again channeling Bogle we
probably would have disagreed on so many
things but we think he's wonderful where
he had great quote where he said during
crisis you know most people want to want
to do the don't just sit there do
something but the reality is you'd be
better off with don't just do something
stand there you know sit sit there do
nothing again so for most people we said
the whole point of this is you have to
have a plan you know how's Peyton
Manning it's football goes the line of
scrimmage you know he has the plan
and you come into this and say look this
is my plan now your plan could be based
it could be look I'm gonna do global
market portfolio rebalance once a year
so rebalancing has the effect of you're
guaranteed to be adding more to the
stuff that's gone down and sheep and
trimming the stuff that's gone up and
expensive so it's that constant
discipline there's a topic that we
talked about in a podcast with Howard
Marks and Robert naught or it's this
concept of even you could go a step
further and over rebalance or calibrate
meaning you add a little bit more and
maybe if you had 60/40 portfolio you go
back to 60/40 well maybe of stock
valuations are true but you keep you go
65 35 but notice it's never like ninety
ten most investors they want a a super
binary all in all out but in reality
it's better to just trim a little bit
and you get the blended outcome of all
all expectations but yeah as if you have
the plan and one of the beauties of a
lot of approaches today is you can
automate those suckers you know we've
said we demonstrate for public assets
most people you build your portfolio you
let it sit let it were in the background
and you just should never touch it again
if it's automated and so we have a
digital offering that does this and as
well many others and it makes the
adjustments for you so you don't have to
worry about you almost see it as a
savings account and it just kind of
keeps you your hands out of the cookie
jar but if anything you know in times
like these people start at act batshit
crazy there are some things in
dislocations you could add a little bit
but this is all in the periphery right
these are little tilts you want to be
making not wholesale I gotta be all-in
on stocks are all out because all that
matters is this sort of sleep sleep at
night portfolio and I love to sleep I
really really do I have a young kid just
warranty now as well as we all are it's
probably not sleeping as much but but
the portfolio is not bothering me
because you have all this stuff planned
ahead of time and it takes away a little
bit of the interest in mucking with it
yeah I know a lot of people like to talk
about that